المزيد ينضم الينا من لندن اللواء الطيار
مامون ابو نوار الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بك معنا نحاول ان نفهم
معك قراءه لهذا التطور الجديد في محطه
زباروجا والتهام الموجه للقوات الروسيه
بنشر صواريخ غراد هناك ما الذي نفهمه من
هذا التحذير من الجانب الاوكراني
يعني بشكل عام نشاهد الان في اوكرانيا هي
حاله من حالات الحرب
المبنيه على التضليل وحرب المعلومات ولا
اخره انما الهدف من هذه العمليات وانا
اعتقد انها جامد وبطيئه الان هي لاعاده
السيطره على بعض المواقع المواقع من خلال
هجمات معاكسه من قبل الطرفين
مثل هذه الحاله يعني لن تؤدي الى وقت
اطلاق نار في المستقبل
الطرفين الى الايذاء المتبادل
الطرفين يعني لكن
لا يمكن ان نتصور ان سوف يكون هنالك
انتصار عسكري من قبل اوكرانيا على روسيا
او روسيا ان تتصل عسكريا بشكل شامل هذه
سوف تبقى حرب هذه
الاستراتيجيه التي تتحدث عنها وهي الايذاء
للطرفين ما مداها هل يمكن ان بالفعل همم
تهدد محطه زبرهوجيه بشكل همم يعني قد
يتسبب بماساه اخرى في اوكرانيا
انا لا اعتقد الطرفين حريصين على هذا لكن
هذه ما يسمى بالانجليزيه امبليوس كاين
يعني غير واضحه يعني همم لنهايه تستخدم من
ضمن حرب المعلومات بحرب اللوم على الطرفين
يعني من قبل الطرفين يستخدموا هذا لكن سوف
تكون كارثه كبيره العالم
او بالنسبه الى استخدام او انا يعني
استبعد هذا كليا بالنسبه للروسي او
الاوكراني يعني سمعنا عن القنبله لكن هذا
لم يحصل في المستقبل او استخدام القنبله
همم
نقديه الكهرومغناطيسيه
بان واشنط تسعى الى اطاله امد الحرب هل
تعتقد بانها دقيقه
قريبا من الدقه لكن انا اعتقد الظروف
مواتيه الان التهاب الى المفاوضات من قبل
الطرفين وتنغير اهداف الحرب تبعه يبدو في
تحقيقه يعني السيطره على ما حصل عليه ضم
الجمهوريات الاخره اوكرانيا يعني من الصعب
بمكان السعاده هذه الاراضي هذا ما اراه
المستقبل ممكن يعني الان ال ال العمليات
سوف تكون عطيه جدا من قبل الطرفين ممكن
نشاهد هذا في الربيع ممكن ان نشاهد بعضهم
فاضل ونعمل بها هذا لانه يعني هنالك
السلام النبويه بالنسبه للعالم المهمه لم
تدائي كله له تداعيات كبيره على العالم
ككل واعتقد ان سوف يصل الى حل في المستقبل
كله حربا تنتهي واعتقد اخرين لسه لسه
العسكري والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك